today I'll show who's that squad is red
and stranger things are strange looking
a little bit of Lukey all that so much
more on this episode of fat man on
Batman
well Batman I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith
I'm a gym Issa's we're back for the warm
greeting yeah welcome to the new stages
folks this is the new fat cave these are
our new monitors courtesy of TCL [ __ ]
sweet monitors we'll be able to put
clips in them and [ __ ] like that this
week know that we're not interested in
that which might chitchat with you all
but these will be useful and not the
very least of which is look they'll help
keep us thin because that's what we
looked like when we were on so every
time we come in here we'll be like gotta
[ __ ] put the chip stone it'll shame
us into health speaking of shaming us
into health in Suicide Squad yeah as a
healthy box-office mark it's doing very
well at the box office there was a
figure that people spoke about in the
beginning and the gloom and doom days of
like this movie there's gonna be a
disaster like BBS and stuff like that
but they said if it hits 600 million is
undeniably a oh hey not a breakeven a
[ __ ] massive hit for Warner Brothers
and it has passed 600 million bucks yeah
well what it's doing okay yeah they'll
be fine five so that's a big win for the
for the DC Universe movies yeah there
was much rejoicing
there was also box-office reporting
around the time the first weekend drop
on the second weekend drop was somewhat
precipitous Deadshot rappelling off a
building
it was something like 60% from first
week the second week which feels bad and
is not good 68 doesn't feel as good as
69 no that's what they were hoping as
many pointed out that is pretty much the
exact same drop-off the guardians of the
galaxy had right yes so so the and I am
a Marvel fan as I am a DC fan I'm more
of a Marvel fans of laman DC movie fans
yes but that to draw some sort of
correlation between second weekend drop
and quality of movie or quality
reception is somewhat tenuous I would
also like to point this out
I think these DC movies right now seem
to be playing like Star Trek movies in
as much as they have their audience and
that audience comes out in full force
and they could do a bunch of business
but the Marvel movies it seems like and
I have no scientific qualification for
this they seem to play beyond what you
would call the base right like my mom is
familiar with those movies my brother
might you know it's I always use my mom
as a reference point that shouldn't go
my brother will go out and see like how
he's like I saw Captain America Civil
War he goes to stuff that he's not
necessarily into he doesn't go to comic
movies generally but he likes following
the Marvel story you know Batman V
Superman he was like I was like you see
it and he was like no not yet but I
guess I you know it was like he wasn't
no there was no sense of responsibility
I feel I could just using him as a
strawpoll or whatever the [ __ ] it feels
like those Marvel movies travel beyond
just the Marvel audience right and you
know you can make a bunch of money with
just the DC audience as we've seen but
hopefully now with Geoff Johns [ __ ]
the Chow riding the fragility call that
the reins
I think this what do you call that chuck
wagon chuck wagon is gonna be pulling up
to the gravy train I lost my [ __ ] now
but I think I think Jeff John's being on
board then you're gonna start sitting
you got again you got to remember Jeff
John's is the guy who's also involved in
all those Berlanti TV shows like I saw
Jeff go pitch
supergirl the day they pitched it how
weird that I eventually wound up gonna
direct an episode this season but he's
you know his work on these characters at
DC particularly like flash translated
directly into that wonderful flash TV
show so this is a guy who knows how to
do the beating heart of comic books that
is so far been encased in armor and
bitterness from space characterize some
of the early stuff so I think that's the
that's positive sign in a big direction
I've in other words right now the DC
movies been playing to the base and the
base is huge so that's great look 600
[ __ ] million Batman V Superman I know
you know everyone's like mean it didn't
do as much as this side of their thing
but it did make a ton even [ __ ] 5060
million bucks so now that Geoff Johns is
in there working on the heart of it all
I think you're gonna watch that base
grow like think about it man [ __ ]
suicides clubbing at six hundred million
bucks is pretty astounding
yeah I mean there's nobody new this book
there are three metrics means address in
movies there's box off hold on give a
[ __ ] single mark single marks [ __ ]
talkin goodness okay three metrics
box-office which is arguably the most
important that's what makes you make
more money's there is critical response
which these days is the least important
because critics do not set the tenor and
the tone for what an audience does any
except for awards pictures words
pictures totally like that's very
helpful there if you're making the Woody
Allen movie that you need critics to
like what do y'all know me right you can
if you're like if you're critic you can
either hell or a sale a comic book movie
and it's you're probably not gonna make
a dent except like oh that's the plot
like I read the reviews just to be like
what is it about because I'm hungry for
the information right so I pin ioan
aside I'm just like oh that's the plot
oh that happens I like spoilers but in
terms of awards movies totally
absolutely make a difference
broken by critics as a kid who is an
indie film kid who was broken in a
positive way by critics long before it
is broken in the other way by critics
like that's absolutely true man they can
make they can really make a young
filmmakers career but you know the you
know who said it best
[ __ ] computer O'Toole in ratatouille
when you know they talk about like the
in support of the new right but but yeah
anyway back to you then the third
veteran hey kids remember ratatouille
feels like a minute ago but really was
probably a decade at this point but you
should go watch that ratatouille [ __ ]
even Patton Oswalt's like was I in
ratatouille that was a long time ago
chops take your references I was the rat
he's amazing I move that will [ __ ]
movies amazing you know what I give me a
single mmm a single giant [ __ ]
defendant that don't back off right
thank you
ratatouille is amazing [ __ ] movie
I'll bring it up any old time back to
the two-shot is CinemaScore which is
what audiences think at the end of every
movie in certain theaters around the
country they will poll people as they
leave home like Paula I thought you
liked that movie look I like it a lot
better now that's true honey is that
cheating I was pollster she's like I'm
being pulled as well things went dirty
fast yeah well they always do but like
that is how the audience feels about a
thing and the CinemaScore grade is
always like a plus a down to F no
Suicide Squad is that incredibly well at
the box office
yes not incredibly well with the critics
yes and not as well as they would have
liked with the audience what would the
audience score the audience score was a
B now that I mean in my sort of
educational career was about as good as
it got I was a straight-a student and
some people will say I'm a straight end
filmmaker
actually if you average the early my
earlier better work with my newer more
puzzling baffling work I probably get to
vatted
low CD and so beware to me would be
amazing beans great I gotta be [ __ ]
CinemaScore on yoga hosers as it comes
out in theaters this week it has it
coming out September 2nd with an early
screening on August 30th a fathom events
in theater screening where you can see
me do it intro 30 minute intro to to the
movie and then the movie plays and stuff
expect our cinema score to be very low
you know that's just the way it goes but
you're right those three factors those
three metrics
decide a hit and see that what's been
the problem so far with the DC movies is
that they've done well the box-office I
mean the 900 million made them Indies to
check that box is by any accounts a hit
and the critical response they don't
care because that does not make a break
a movie but it's that service for as low
as it is and be for that kind of movie
is low is because if you're playing to
an audience that's supposed to love this
stuff they should love this stuff and if
they don't then they don't and so I
think that that's again what Geoff Johns
is hoping and we're hoping that he can
help do it's a certain rise that seems
really bringing that overall score right
like make it play to everybody as
opposed to just the base the base will
always love in the base will always go
but you don't get to like a billion for
a billion five unless everybody it goes
beyond the base right into people who
are like I see like three movies a year
I saw that Captain America movie it was
good like those people where you're like
wait you didn't [ __ ] sick you never
get irritated people that are just like
really go like twice a year I'm like
[ __ ] is wrong with you
that's right they're two movies right
they're just [ __ ] call [ __ ] how often
you go to movies I'm like not much I
scream a lot but I support the art but I
see a lot of things that I pay for them
trying to think whether the last movie I
saw in theatres was I guess Squad yeah
the last one you pay for
I think squad yeah cuz I saw the
premiere and then I saw it again I think
so yeah but I wanted to go see something
came out this weekend when I was like
that looked good the thing I still want
to see his hell or high water what's
that
then Jeff
bridges Chris Pine sort of mio Western
thing yeah they're just Chris Botti ya
know right that mark barnard in the same
room with Chris Pine you'll make that
noise again yeah he's good actor man oh
I like him in most things I look forward
to his equivocation yeah he's a good guy
he's alright ain't good
he's got that look I look forward to his
Steve Trevor Trevor Trevor Trevor in
Wonder Woman yes we know we know what
you thought of the Suicide Squad
would you like to encapsulate your
feelings I enjoyed Suicide Squad I
understood you know why some people are
like this [ __ ] ain't for me like you
know yeah um give me a single give me a
single give me that single you give it
to me I enjoy it but I understood when
some people were not enthused about it
but I'll say this my kid obviously loved
the movie go back to the to show my kid
loved the movie quite a bit a big bad
way she's really connected with it but
mostly cuz the name thing Harley Quinn I
think but she was like I love it she's
crying so in the movie I'm like crying
because you don't like it and she's like
crying because is the best thing ever
I'm like you do realize that directed
the movie that you're in you could say
that was the best thing ever and she
didn't she's like I bet the Joker hardly
she's very booth bubble experienced so
anyway her grandparents Byron and Gail
Jen's parents who lived with us and have
lived with us since the kid was a baby
they're always like they're really cool
about keeping up with like you know
whatever the kids interested in they
like to be like you know involved in it
not involved in it but they'll look at
it too so they can talk to her and stuff
they're very close friends so they were
like we're gonna go see Suicide Squad
now it's like a whole listen you old
stirs pushing 70 I don't know if you're
gonna get much out of there's gonna be
baffling to you guys you might want to
see something else and they went
and they loved it yeah and that weird
mmm very strange but I'm not that weird
just like if you like that kind of movie
like I did I like to lock those were my
thoughts mmm on Suicide Squad there's a
whole video about that you can go watch
up that minute Batman however mr. mark
bernard in' never got to weigh in with
his thoughts he saw him before me I did
see before him he did he saw commercials
for you mark sees stuff for the LA Times
you can't always talk about it until it
comes out and stuff like that
spoilers and [ __ ] well not on camera but
when the cameras go off he's like was
Batman after dark
yeah that's when we tow buddies just
talk man ain't nothing professional and
[ __ ] just back buddies just John back
buddies man [ __ ] like dudes and prisoner
back buddies and [ __ ] that's what we
were like [ __ ] talking about who
would you hear what you see and thoughts
and stuff now after all that
homoeroticism we get to share marks
thoughts with you right here cause I'm
fat man I'm Batman
take a give him a big fat [ __ ] single
mmm the bat single if you will tell him
what you thought I did not love this was
that squad go back to 2-shot back to a
single no I have I have a couple of
specific problems my first being Amanda
Waller is forming a team with the
express purpose of being able to deal
with and metahuman threat like Superman
dropping a building on the white house
or Superman doing awful [ __ ] or
basically Superman the bad version was
her worst case scenario yes so she forms
a team with Captain Boomerang on it yes
who's going to be what to evil Superman
with a boomerang as I said boy boy had a
kryptonite
boomerang oh and take him out I would
like I've got to get that slipping up
guys
can get to high places quickly because
that'll help that's not creepy I that's
Krypton I like that yeah look not if
that is hurt you just need it you just
need a minute Bob yeah you needed
somebody to dodge spoilers but here
comes a sign but here comes the science
and drop it
writer if you are going to like if if
her purpose is to be able to deal with
Superman then this is not the t me bill
to deal with Superman if all she was
doing was trying to sell the government
so she could build a team then I need to
see what she Lehman one of that team for
like if it is Task Force X to do bad
[ __ ] show me her sending them on a
mission to do something actually
horrible hmm and then have it go awry
then you get to redeem Amanda Waller as
not a like awful tactician Stratton
cessation whatever the president of
strategy is tripped injury mister teeth
absolute strategic and then my other
fundamental problem with that movie is
that poking holes in your ruined if I'm
so no you're ruining it now you can't
ruin it for me go ahead poke another
hole is the Enchantress yeah is the boy
she was that was a clear storyline
yeah what's what is she doing why is she
doing it she's doing the thing with the
glowing machine in the city to do what
to do why why I don't understand Amanda
Waller discovers his woman and like the
chalice with her body her spirit in it
next to one another one that she doesn't
safeguard like she's got Enchantress's
heart in a box would rigged up two nukes
and [ __ ] she's gonna stab it to make her
do stuff the brother who has the same
powers in the same shape thing she's
like boys are far less aggressive than
girls she leave it there he'll be fine
putting on a shelf somewhere what man
has never been destructive yes God now
the agenda sure we gotta look out for
her the entire history of mankind is
based on men being horrible once again
man you got a [ __ ] storyteller
watching your movie you better tell some
story so here's here's my fix yes for
this movie which will also solve me what
is the Joker doing exactly okay other
than just being the Joker occasionally
but
having no actual impact on the story
whatsoever the Joker
kidnaps Amanda Waller the Joker once
Harley back he decides the way to get
Harley back now that she's been in roped
into this task force ask X is to kidnap
the person running task force X so the
entire movie is the Suicide Squad going
to rescue them in a while or from the
Joker and instead of these faceless
awful bad guys that we have to kill
they're the Joker's bad guys like make
it to it it's the army of the Joker
against the Suicide Squad bunch of
clowns psycho clown yeah like I don't so
if they could kill I'm going either
crazy it's all so he Unleashed him from
a [ __ ] death row or something so when
they get killed everyone's like yeah but
it's also their bad guys yeah they're
allowed to kill people that's why you
get an army of bad guys The Joker pulls
his henchmen from a yes kill puppy
shelter that makes everybody in the
audience go calvo's Fox you're
absolutely right what a good [ __ ] see
I'd see that movie too so that way you
get the romance between the Joker and
Harley in a big bad way because the joke
was doing all of this to get Harley back
it seems like the romance pun intended
was back doored in this movie don't you
think I feel like it might have I've
heard some reports that things were
trimmed out so as to make him more like
make that relationship more affectionate
which I appreciate because I actually
like that aspect of the movie where I'm
like well it's kind of cute instead of
doing the old chestnut of like he's an
abusive dick to her like he was actually
kind of sweet on her but apparently in
earlier drafts he was he was a pretty
abusive but they trim that I think it
was a smart trend that goes smart I
don't know if I came from the studio or
whatever but yeah I think that was
actually a good poll because that was
one of the things I really liked about
the movie was oh they like each other a
lot it's kind of sweet and it's weird
[ __ ] you know Harold and Maude way
like show me that codependency show me
that Sid Nancy show me all of that juice
between them and have that be the spine
that this movies is functioning on and
not be attached was that her crazy globe
machine
do something I don't give a [ __ ] about
an Amanda Waller not being very good at
putting people together for an express
purpose and just [ __ ] happen it think
you think it was weird when Amanda
Waller just [ __ ] shot people on her
side is that what this movie is all my
live the but you taught when you saw
before me you were alike you loved the
opening and you're the first like 30
minutes a lot of fun yeah the first leg
let's go squad you guys here's what
everybody is and fun introductions and
little backstories Jeff Jones and Geoff
Johns and also there was the the story
that had emerged after the movie came
out those that there were two competing
cuts of this film and they were tested
there was the the filmmakers God gave it
a or had cut his film who I loved I
loved him as a filmmaker I think he did
a great job with this but boy he's
[ __ ] taking it hard over the movie
man they went after him so hardcore but
he submitted a [ __ ] that was very and I
was and you know what for the record at
the premiere Suicide Squad like there's
a story reported that he was like [ __ ]
Marvel it was so innocuous like I was
there in the room it wasn't like oh ho
ho the war is on he's like someone from
the audience was like [ __ ] Marvel and he
was again [ __ ] or something but it
wasn't like you know [ __ ] Marvel anyway
about this he submitted a cut that was
sort of very dark and very serious and
then one of others asked the company who
cut the first trail in the second
trailer the second trail everybody loved
yes Blitzen it was all fun and poppin it
moved they asked that company to submit
a cut of the film I submit myself as
somebody who is a 20 year plus veteran
of the film business
that's rare yes that's that's that's
very rare that the control of any movie
is ceded to the marketing department
usually and it sounds like these cats
were hired it wasn't an in-house one of
those marketing so that but those
trailers were working that's that's the
movie that people are getting ready to
see so I guess they were like shouldn't
the movie lean toward that I mean
Warner Brothers does a thing incredibly
well which is selling movie and the open
can be the hundred and twenty-seven
million dollar gross is entirely based
upon the marketing like that's how you
get you get people excited to come to
your movie trailers campaigns posters
appearances in talk shows and late night
and all that stuff that's a marketing
win it is the second and third weekend
that our how did in the movie resonate
with audience where and they wanted like
people responding so strongly to the to
the ad materials they wanted that
feeling out of the movie and so for the
first time I can remember they tested
two competing cuts in the film and then
decided to lean way more heavily on the
trailer companies cut and the David Ayer
cut and I think that's what you see in
the movie you see the first 40 minutes
or so being like a big trailer hmm and
poppy and moving in kneel drop city and
expensive needle drops like you wanna
get Kanye West for 20 seconds in your
movie that costing billions of dollars
and they didn't care I could give it to
me give it to me the Rolling Stones give
it to me David Bowie make it rain lot of
musicians got rich off this booth huh
and so and then the second half of the
movie felt like it's one day but I
wanted it to be and it gets very dark
it's very urban thriller it gets hurting
grin and I feel like at least for me
those two things never quite meshed I'm
not saying that I liked one over the
other but I wanted them I wanted the
movie to feel as if it was a whole and
it didn't quite I liked your movie I
liked the idea of your movie I hoped
that the amazing sequel somebody steal
that idea like don't we won't even care
would you care I mean no would literally
let's be honest if they made a movie and
it turned out to be exactly what you
just pitched would you be mad no
whatever they went out in public and
like we stole this from Bernard and as
long as they said that I would be fine
what if they were like we stole this
from this nameless faceless anonymous
internet person some anonymous
we stole from the blurred community yeah
I mean it's like hey if if they if they
decide they want to make Road one the
way we had talked about it yeah then
like Bravo like that I just want to see
that movie yeah if they decide they want
to make the Joker after Harley because
somebody steals Harley from him movie
100% hmm you know like all about that in
Harley movie they announced what's
happening yeah they did they just not
something else - what did they announce
there was big DC news with Oh [ __ ]
Justice League dark yes Justice League
dark was announced with and what they've
talked about doing it before and then it
went quiet like we're taking it off the
books daddy about the tour oh we're
supposed to that's right but now it's
back on the books in the very capable
hands of doug liman yes that got me
excited cuz I love that [ __ ] the Tom
Cruise of tomorrow 20 title movie it was
live die repeat lived edge of tomorrow :
live die repeat that was the movie
supposed to be called originally all you
need is a kill which was such a [ __ ]
metal title why did they get rid of that
probably because kill didn't mark it
well [ __ ] that man that separates the
wheat from the chaff you're the kind of
person that's like I'll see a movie with
kill in a title to kill a mockingbird
you have [ __ ] orcs by the way Warner
Brothers just sold Suicide Squad yeah
lots of people [ __ ] a man so they
should have went with all you need a
skill instead they went with edge of
tomorrow it sounded like a [ __ ] like
soap opera I know from the 70s tomorrow
I love you John I don't love you I'm
having an abortion edge of tomorrow and
then their poster tagline was live die
repeat but it was printed so large on
most the posters that everyone thought
not everyone in a goodly portion of
people that went to see it thought the
movie was called live die repeat yes so
what did they do on home video
they literally retitled the movie
edge of tomorrow : live die repeat like
if you're the guy that wrote live die
repeat tagline don't you think you like
sue for credit very much just give me
something yeah I want to I want a
[ __ ] co-author credit I came up with
that title buy me a Hyundai yeah that's
the least you could [ __ ] do come on
beg crows I love what did Lyman get
Lyman jazeera's whatever he gots that
movie's [ __ ] dull in that felt really
good and actually to be honest with you
most this stuff he does is really fun
and watchable was the it's not a looper
of a jumper jumper jumper like by all
[ __ ] right shin work to really
enjoyable movie with young Hayden
Christensen yeah what else has he done
mr. mr. Smith is a [ __ ] fun movie and
[ __ ] when she jumps off with the
necklace and boy I did it the first
Bourne movie did that's right which has
[ __ ] one of the most amazing moments
in the [ __ ] cinema history when the
German cops like shiz up sighs that was
insane he's trying to wake up [ __ ]
Matt Damon on the bench in medicine yeah
and then finally [ __ ] just grabs it
and it gives him that Matt Damon first
like I think it's the first time I ever
saw him at do it gives him that I don't
even know I just smirk that I look who's
here give me my single he goes yeah -
I'm good I can't do it that's why I
don't pay me - Matt Damon bucks but that
moment man I talked to Matt Damon for
geeking out and he said Doug Liman
author at that moment yeah he was like
oh he's gone
do this again he's gonna do me a favor
and he moved the camera he's like just
look up right at this angle right here
now do it two more times while you're
holding the baton he goes okay we're
good cut he goes what did you have and
he was like there's this a [ __ ] look
that you gave which is great just in
this one moment so I just wanted to get
it closer and that's what's a movie
that's like one of the things that like
so many people talk about Scott Mosier
after he saw the guy juice pockets with
was like no one I loved man when Matt
grabbed the baton I was like me too so
[ __ ] doug liman responsible for that
in a moment he's gonna direct Justice
League dark that jumper movie was kind
of like a comic book movie selling it
felt like it very much so I trust him
with the source material I was writing
it but I mean they got a cartoon trail
did you see that
for I just watched it online on over the
movies older if it's I think it's coming
it's called Justice League dark and it's
got Batman in it and [ __ ] Swamp Thing
and Constantine and Zatanna and looks
like Felix Faust like [ __ ] it's
pretty bad a dead man
the demon Etrigan and Jason blood so it
looks kind of it looks good man this
first time you've seen like an animated
was gonna say first thing we seen that I
miss one thing that's not true there was
a whole Swamp Thing cartoon at one point
they made action figures of can you
believe that [ __ ]
so that look that you can see what
Justice League dark movie might look
like I think it's funny when they
announced it a bunch of people right
you know the who've been riding like
more these DC movies are too dark
first announcement comes out is like
Justice League dark we understand yeah
they're like isn't that redundant now so
Justice League dark they're not calling
it that they're calling it something
else no I would if I was them just
[ __ ] lean in the DC Universe I believe
that's what's go I don't think it's
Justice League dark I don't think that
would create brand confusion for people
that don't know there are a bunch of
people out there don't know the Justice
League if you believe that Warner
Brothers gonna teach him over the course
the next year but to teach them about
Justice League dark too much so a cult
yeah Justice League Justice League :
metal ma'am and a Minutemen are the
Batman fight big deal with the demon
world ma'am in a minute minute ma'am in
a minute alright there you go so anyway
doug liman drug Justice League dark guys
just announced that news I for one and
all for you thank you hundred percent my
name right it won't and that's all the
DC news we have for you today right that
we took you from squad to dark dark dark
to darker it's and there's so much more
to talk about but we'll talk about it on
another episode yeah a fat man on Batman
there it is man Batman back now I'm
Kevin Smith I'm walking home and join us
here next episode which I think will be
in like two days same fat time same fat
channel SModcast calm
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
a man's meat Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder